The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The equivalent cost
of manufacturing in China,
as best as we can determine,
is in the order of $1, $1.30,
$1.50-- somewhere in that
range with the error bars.
So keep those numbers in your
head as we dive into price.
Because now we're
going to be talking
about what the market
is offering to pay
and what that spread is
between the cost and the price.
So you have, in your slide deck,
a list of different websites.
I guess you have web
[? e-sits. ?] You have
websites, email list serves,
blogs, and Twitter feeds--
different sources of information
for collecting data from PV.
And I should add one more
to this list, which wasn't
on there, but should be there.
PVinsights.com.
This is where you can find
it pretty up-to-date spot
prices for wafers, cells,
modules, and so forth.
Does anybody know
what a spot price is?
What does it mean, a spot price?
Spot price means I'm
desperate to buy.
I need to buy it right now.
I pick up a phone and
call somebody and say,
I'm willing to pay you.
So there's no long
term contract involved.
It's usually a one-time deal.
That's a spot price.
A long term contract,
on the other hand,
says, no, no, really.
I have a factory.
It's 100 megawatts.
And I need wafer
supply for five years.
Let's lock ourselves
into a price.
Maybe we visit it
every 2 and 1/2 years,
but that's a long term contract.
So these are spot
prices and they provide
a variety of information.
The information
for today is free.
If you want historical
data, you have
to sign up, become
a member, and pay.
But there are other websites
like this-- various consulting
groups-- that acquire and
gather information, PVinsights.
So you have a variety
of different sites
to grab information
that could be
useful for your class projects.
We're going to talk again
about the dynamics of price.
And that is driven, in
large part, by-- well,
we agreed to call
it different things.
Support mechanisms, tax breaks,
incentives-- but in reality,
they're support for PV.
Recognizing that with
$1.30, $1.10 cost,
and then you add on top
of that the profit margin,
even if you assume a very
meager margin of 15%,
you're-- and then
the balances systems,
and then the installation
costs on top of that--
you're not reaching grid parity
in the majority of markets.
Not with that sort of
cost structure today.
With innovation
and moving forward
into the future and
scale-- we'll get there,
I'm fairly confident--
but today, we
don't have the cost structure
necessary to match, say,
a subsidized
coal-fired power plant.
So there are a variety of
different support mechanisms,
a variety of different subsidies
in different countries,
and different states
within the United States.
And you can think about these
as the carrot, the stick,
and the hybrid.
The carrot meaning the margin
enhancement, the stick being
the penalty if you
produce too much carbon,
for instance, and some variety
of mixtures between the two.
So in terms of
margin enhancement--
the carrot-- what
mechanisms exist?
Let me break it down
very simply into-- we'll
look in two
different categories.
We'll look at what the United
States has mostly done,
which are tax relief and
grants and soft loans.
So let's describe
what that means.
When I bought the panels on
top of the house in 2007,
we paid out of the box somewhere
in the order of $7 to $8
per watt peak.
And after tax rebate coming
from the federal government,
and some additional support
from the state of Massachusetts,
the final price tag wound up
being from say $18,000 plus
down to about
$12,000 to $14,000.
And then there's revenue coming
in from offsets and so forth.
So this is a one-time deal.
I could have installed
those panels in my basement
and still gotten the
tax break, right?
Because it's per watt peak,
not per kilowatt hour produced.
The rebates based
on carbon emissions
is based on the amount
of energy it produces.
That gives you an incentive
to maximize the efficiency
of the installation.
But just a one-time
tax rebate doesn't.
However, what the one-time
tax rebate allows you to do
is decrease the
upfront sticker price.
So if I'm trying to sell
you system on your house,
US installers are
convinced that it's
a lot easier to
sell you the system
if the price tag is lower.
If I can say, well this is
the real cost, but wait, wait,
there's more.
We'll give you this tax rebate,
this tax rebate, draw a line.
The final amount you pay is
this lower amount right here.
The other mechanism of margin
enhancement, if you will,
is what's called
a feed-in tariff.
Now, a feed-in tariff
works as follows.
A feed-in tariff says, OK,
if you're paying-- let's say,
in the state of Massachusetts,
we don't have one.
We don't have a feed-in
tariff here in Massachusetts.
But imagine if we did.
You, as a residential
customer, are paying $0.18
per kilowatt hour
for your electricity.
But if you have solar panels
on your roof, the utility,
if you will-- the state
of Massachusetts--
is willing to pay you $0.30
per kilowatt hour for that PV
electricity.
Recognizing the additional
value that that PV
is adding to the state.
Reducing the need for
additional transmission lines,
reducing the amount
of investment
in new coal-fired power plants,
reducing the health detriment
to the local communities around
the coal plants, and so forth.
So a feed-in tariff is meant
to give an incentive-- a market
pull incentive, if you will--
to install PV on your house.
Or in a field.
And this is the mechanism that
has been in use in Germany.
And because it's a
market-driven mechanism,
it rewards the most efficient
systems that are out there.
If you install that
system in your basement,
you're not going to be
producing kilowatt hours,
and hence you're
not going to benefit
from the feed-in tariff.
Now it's a tricky business
to decide where exactly
to fit that feed-in tariff.
Right?
If you go too low, people
aren't going to move.
They're going to say,
eh, no, not enough.
Not enough to make me
want to install solar.
If the feed-in
tariff is too high,
you're going to get this
massive onrush of people
coming to install solar.
And now you're going to
have to finance it, right?
And the money has to
come from somewhere.
In Germany, the money
comes from the rate payers,
not from the state.
Which means that if you install
solar panels on your house,
all of us have to help
pay for the electricity
that you sell back to the grid.
So our rate goes up from $0.18
per kilowatt hour to, say,
18.2 cents per kilowatt hour.
In the beginning, we
don't notice it at all.
But then if Joe starts putting
solar panels up, as well,
and then, let's say, 50%
of us put solar panels up,
now obviously we're
paying a lot more.
And it gives more of an
incentive for more people
to put the solar
panels up on the roof.
And of course,
the price goes up.
So the feed-in
tariff is a very--
it is a market-driven incentive.
And hence, it is very skillful
at rewarding the most efficient
installations.
But from a government
point of view,
it requires very
structured, rigorous,
and deaf-to-manipulation
of the feed-in tariff
rate-- the decline of the rate
versus time-- to ensure that A,
the installers aren't reaping
an enormous profit, and B,
that the system doesn't become
unsustainable over time.
That the burden
on the rate payers
is not so great that
they're shouldered
in for 20 years paying these
excessively high rates.
So it rewards first adopters,
it allows the market to predict,
versus rate of growth, what
the reward rate will be.
And it allows you to
glide into grid parity.
So we're at a situation today
where we're not at grid parity.
In 10, 20 years, we're
likely to be there.
And so the declining rate
of the feed-in tariff
allows you to glide back in.
In the United States, the
tax rebate, unfortunately--
because of the way
our political system
works-- it tends to get renewed
in a very frequent rate.
Every two years, it
seems, it's going up
for debate and discussion.
Should we continue it?
Should we not continue it?
It becomes a big political
struggle just to get it passed.
And as a result,
everybody uses up
their energy trying
to pass this thing
and renew it, as
opposed to saying,
gee, what's the best way
to decrease this over time
so that we can kind of
glide into grid parity?
So we have some
issues in the US,
more related to how our
political system doesn't work.
But there are examples of
this throughout the world,
in terms of what are
states and countries doing
to enhance the margins to create
market-pull incentives to allow
solar to be installed
on the grid?
And the panels
that are installed
could come from anywhere.
They could be produced
in Guam and they could
qualify for the feed-in tariff.
So it doesn't discriminate
against particular regions
of the world.
Another thing to add
here is that this is just
the support from the state,
from the public sector.
From the private sector,
what is possible?
Well what is possible is
what's called a power purchase
agreement.
And this was alluded
to during our tour.
What is a power
purchase agreement?
A power purchase agreement is--
instead of you buying a system
and putting it up on
your roof and having
to pay all that money
up front, what you do
is you enter an agreement
with the installer.
They will put the panels
up on your roof for free
because they're getting the
financing, say, from Morgan
Stanley, from the Bank of Joe.
So the Bank of Joe is financing
the panels on your roof.
So the panels went
up on your roof.
You didn't pay a penny.
But you inked an agreement
with me, the installer,
because I just borrowed money
from Joe at a certain interest
rate.
And you inked an
agreement with me
that you'll pay a certain
amount for your electricity
over the next 10, 15, 20
years, however long it
is-- usually 12.
And that rate may be
a little bit higher
than what it is today,
but it's certainly
going to be lower if current
price inflation continues
for the price of electricity.
It will certainly be lower than
what the price of electricity
will be in 12 years.
And so you'll make money.
I'll make money because there's
a spread between the rate
at which I'm borrowing
the money from the bank
and what you're paying
me for those panels--
for renting the panels
on the roof, if you will.
For buying the electricity
from those panels.
So everybody's making money.
And the bank's making
money, obviously,
because they're charging an
interest rate on the loan.
And so with those
financing schemes,
where it's called a power
purchase agreement, bank loans
the money to the installer,
the installer loans the panels
on the roof of the
customer, and the customer
pays a fixed price
for the electricity.
That allows everybody to
make money from day one,
as long as there's
capital in play.
It requires capital
to be in play,
meaning it requires
the Bank of Joe
to be willing to lend
money to me, the installer.
If the Bank of Joe
doesn't want to lend,
then that isn't an option.
And so you see many of these
very large deals being forged
with the investment banks
between large installers-- say,
SunPower, SunEdison, and so
forth-- in New York City.
It's becoming an
increasingly popular form
of financing solar panels.
You may stand to make more
money as an individual
by buying the panels up
front because then you reap
the entire benefit
of your investment.
You're not sharing
the investment benefit
with the installer.
You're not sharing
the investment benefit
with the bank.
But that requires,
again, access to capital.
And not everybody has a spare
$14,000, $15,000 lying around
to put solar on the roof.
Question.
AUDIENCE: What's the
incentive of the, I guess,
whoever's installing
the panels on
to buy the electricity from you.
Why would you buy it
from you, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So over the past 10 years--
say, from 2000 to 2009--
in the state of Massachusetts,
the price of electricity
increased by 15%.
So if you compare what did
it take per kilowatt hour
at the beginning and
the end-- normalize
for inflation, 15% inflation--
in the price of electricity.
And there are a variety
of reasons for that.
We're at the end of a
natural gas pipeline,
so even if the price of
natural gas goes down,
it takes a lot to get it to us.
Sometimes shipments
go in by boat.
Other times, up the
actual pipeline itself.
And then, other forms
of fossil fuel-- oil,
especially-- has
experienced a rise
in prices of the last few years.
And so for a variety of
reasons, including those
and including a difficulty
in transmission,
and including limited new
power plants coming online,
the price has gone up.
And as a result, if
you project forward,
you could say, OK, let's
hedge our bets here.
We can estimate that the price
is going to go up another 15%
between now and the next decade.
So what I'm going
to do is to say,
this is the price today,
this is the price tomorrow--
in 10 years, right?
I'm going to sell
you electricity here.
And so it's almost
like the deal--
I don't know if anybody signs
up for the natural gas lock-in
price during winter with NStar.
You probably see the
envelope in the mail,
or maybe your landlord does.
But NStar-- the utility
company around this area--
will allow you to lock in
a price for natural gas
per therm-- per unit
of natural gas--
over the winter, that is
slightly above the market
rate in the fall.
With the understanding
that prices
tend to spike during winter,
and you're able to hedge,
you're able to reduce risk.
And so really what it is is
a risk mitigation strategy.
And it's good enough
for most people.
I know two people
on our street alone
have entered power
purchase agreements
as means of financing
their solar installations.
So let's discriminate once
again between the private sector
that's trying to sell
you the panels-- I say,
Omar, you have to buy my panels.
Let me sweeten the deal here.
You don't have to
pay a penny upfront.
We'll introduce a power
purchase agreement.
Versus what the state
is doing, right?
Whether that's the national
government or the state level
is doing to try to get the
installers and other industries
growing within
their organization.
And as well, several
of the EU states
meeting their Kyoto
Protocol obligations
to reduce carbon emissions
by a certain amount by 2020.
So we're going to do a deep
dive into the German case,
just because it is so
interesting and so exemplary,
in terms of increasing the
amount of PV on the grid.
And one thing to
note, just upfront,
this is the insulation
map of Europe.
Insulation being
the solar radiance,
the total solar
resource available,
shown in this barely
distinguishable little legend
down here.
Blue being low, red being high.
And Germany is
right here, as they
would say, from herzen Europas,
from the heart of Europe
right there.
Right in the middle.
And this is the insulation
comparison, again,
between Germany
the United States.
Same scale over here.
A lot less solar resource
in Germany, even than
in the Northeastern part
of the United States.
Yet there was about half of
all solar panels installed here
last year.
Why?
Well first off, it's
high electricity prices.
Secondly, there is
a feed-in tariff
that gives an
incentive for solar
to be installed on a grid.
So what I'm going to do is
go over several slides coming
from the ministry in Germany,
describing the growth of solar
and the growth of other
renewables on the grid,
in response to this
feed-in tariff.
So the renewable
energy resources,
if you will, as a share
of the total energy
supply in Germany--
the goal by 2020
is this white bar right here.
And if we look at the
share of renewable sources
in total gross
electricity consumption,
you can see that it's
getting there, right?
17% versus a minimum of 35%.
So working toward those
targets pretty well.
And climbing from 2000 to 2010--
more than doubling, almost
tripling.
This is the electricity,
heat supply,
and fuel supply breakdown.
If we just look at the
electricity component
right here, since that's where
PV falls and contributes,
you can see it's growing.
What you have to keep
in mind is this 17%
of electricity
consumption coming
from renewables-- this
17% is this amount here,
the yellow bar.
And we're looking at
something in the range
of 103 terawatt hours over
the course of a year in 2010.
And out of those
103 terawatt hours,
breaking it out into PV,
biomass, hydro, and wind,
you can see that PV has
accounted for a relatively
small fraction of that total.
The largest, by
far, has been wind.
Wind has reached lower
prices of electricity
faster than solar has.
Differences between the
technology, so we say.
And as a result, the
grid penetration of wind
has preceded that of solar.
But solar is
growing quite a bit.
And this is averaged
over the entire country.
And as I mentioned before,
there are certain regions
within Germany, as you
might guess-- down here,
for instance-- that have
experienced larger grid
penetration of
solar than others.
Just because they have
a larger solar resource
available to them.
So this is the little
fraction here-- growing--
of solar electricity.
These here are the
different legislations
that are being passed,
regulating the feed-in tariff.
Now, the feed-in tariff is
scheduled to reduce gradually
for each year.
Let me show you how that works.
We'll go back to
this German energy
blog by two of our energy
law experts in Germany.
And this describes for you
the German feed-in tariffs
as of 2010.
The Renewable Energy Sources
act-- essentially, one of those
legislations that have
passed-- and it just
shows you what you
can expect over
a variety of different sectors.
Hydro, landfill, gas.
And you can see, it's broken
into very specific details.
Different sizes of
installations, different types
of plants and so forth.
This is bio, geothermal,
onshore wind, offshore wind,
solar radiation,
roof-mounted facilities,
electricity used within
the building facility,
freestanding facilities,
and digression.
Digression means, how much
does it go down per year?
This is based on their best
estimate for the growth
of grid penetration of PV.
They're trying to guess
in the future, how much PV
is going to come onto the
grid by a certain date?
And hence, what the
price will be, as well.
And thus, reduce their
feed-in tariff accordingly.
And since it's impossible
to look into a crystal ball
and nail it-- especially
since this is a nonlinear
system-- the price depends
on the feed-in tariff,
the feed-in tariff depends
on the price, right?
So there's a little bit of
that interaction going on.
They have to reassess,
from time to time, what
the new rates are going to be.
And that's why you have
these various-- well, aside
from the initial-- you have
these various reevaluations
from time to time, looking
at the feed-in tariff.
Now, what has happened
more recently--
there was a reevaluation
in January 2009.
Another mid-2010 that
decreased it even further.
So more recently--
this, unfortunately,
only goes to 2010--
but more recently,
there have been more
significant, stronger cuts
to the feed-in tariff in Germany
in response to a few things.
So let me go over
this real quick.
I'll get back to
that in a second.
First off, this is the payment
of fees in millions of s
versus time that the rate
payers are paying in total.
So that winds up being
something in the order of 135
s per head in Germany.
That's not spread equally
amongst everybody-- per year--
that's not spread equally
amongst everybody.
That's, as well, their
industry bears more,
obviously than the
residential customer would.
But it's a line item of
a few s on your utility
bill per month as a customer.
And that begins to add up.
So Germany has begun putting on
the brakes on the incentives.
And further, if they
look at how much they've
installed versus other
countries-- again,
this is the same chart
we showed last class--
their portion of all new
installations is very large.
And so they began looking
around to the rest of the world,
saying, hey folks, we don't
have a lot of sun here.
Why aren't you doing your part
to put solar on your grids?
Compounded by the
fact that now they
have a growing percentage
of manufacturing
that's not in Germany.
The percentage of German
manufacturing of the PV
modules themselves has
stayed more or less flat.
And so Germany's sitting
here thinking, OK,
we're in a financial
crisis right now.
Something has to give.
Let's put a damper on this
feed-in tariff for a little bit
until the situation
straightens itself out
and until there's more growth
in other markets besides just
Germany.
Let's try to reduce
the incentive
that we give to
put PV on our grid
and maybe increase the share
of PV going onto US, China,
and so forth-- other big
markets around the world.
So that we're not bearing the
sole burden of trying to reduce
the cost of PV to grid parity.
As a result of this-- the
decline in the feed-in tariff
in Germany-- and as a
result of a massive amount
of new production
capacity coming
online in China
and Taiwan, we're
now in an oversupply condition.
What means an
oversupply condition?
What it means is that there are
more PV modules available today
than there are customers to buy
them at the given prices that
are available.
And the price is dictated, in
part, by the feed-in tariff.
And so what you've
seen is-- sorry,
I'm just going to drive through
these slides right over here
till I get to that one.
So what you see is that chart
that Secretary Chu presented
yesterday during his talk.
This was in first
quarter of 2008.
This was when the
market began softening.
Right around here, the
German feed-in tariffs
really started going
down tremendously.
Chinese manufacturing and
Taiwanese manufacturing
really started ramping up
around here, 2007, 2008.
And so what happened?
This here is price, not cost.
Price.
So this is being driven
by market dynamics,
not solely by the
costs of manufacturing.
So we have what people
are willing to pay
for their hours of watt.
So if the feed-in
tariff is going down
in Germany, which is
acquiring 50% of the modules
in the market, that
means that the price
has to come down, as well.
If you're going to be
able to sell your modules,
you're going to have to
sell them at a lower price
because the feed-in
tariff is now lower.
At the same time, you have
now more supply on the market
and you have companies
competing against each other
to get their modules
on the market.
And so prices are going to
come down by that, as well.
So what this chart is telling
you-- let's look at the blues,
for instance.
Let's start here.
These are estimates
made in 2008.
And this blue line
extending forward
is the estimated price-- not
cost-- the estimated price
of what a PV module would
sell for, projected forward
to the end of 2010.
Then, we enter
2009-- the reds here.
And the real prices continue
to drop precipitously.
Again, here we have
the analysts' estimates
for what the price
is going to be,
moving forward to end of 2011.
And you can see that the
analysts' estimates are always
above the actual prices
over the last three years.
Which means that
the actual prices
have fallen faster
than anybody--
or the analysts-- expected to.
Maybe there were
some smart people
in the actual industry who
saw this coming in quite
the same way.
But what this
means is the prices
have come down a lot faster
than what people expected.
I don't think people expected
that Germany would cut
the feed-in tariff rate
quite as large as it did
in '09 and in '10.
And some people, who haven't
been paying attention
to the market, might not
have expected as much supply
to be available from
China as there is today.
Those people should have
been paying better attention.
But that combination of factors
resulted in a much faster price
decline than what
people saw coming.
And as a result,
companies that were
formed in, say, 2007, 2008, and
got venture capital-- and saw
one of these lines right
here and said, oh, we're
going to be able to
intersect them in 2010--
are now looking at these
sorts of prices here.
And saying, oh, gee, we're not
to be able to intersect them
in 2010, it's going
to be more like 2015
before we get our
production costs low enough
to compete at those prices.
And so the venture catalysts
are now sitting back thinking,
so let me get this straight.
You came to us three
years ago and told us
that you'd be cost
competitive by 2010.
But now the story
is you're going
to be cost competitive by 2015.
This kind of smells fishy.
I don't know if I want to
lend you an additional round
here, especially if I
have to wait another five
years before you're profitable.
Let me just cut my losses
and pick up shop and leave.
And your company will go under.
So that's happened a few times.
That's happened in a high
profile way, which we all
know about-- Solyndra.
It's also happened to a few
other companies-- SpectraWatt.
Even earlier ones
at the beginning
of the financial crisis--
OPTI-Solar and others.
So the companies that are
surviving right now-- there
are still more than 100 startup
companies in the United States.
Dozens and dozens of
startup companies in solar.
Those smart ones
that are surviving
are usually in
pre-production stage.
They don't have big
manufacturing lines, hundreds,
thousands of people to pay,
supply chains to pay for,
and customers evaporating,
so they're not
caught in that situation.
That was Solyndra.
They had a big production line.
They had 1,100 people
employed in that line.
And they had customers lined up.
They had suppliers shipping
in materials that they
were converting into product.
And some of the
customers disappearing
were not willing to pay
as high prices anymore.
And that leads to a very
difficult situation.
You don't have a
cash cushion, you
don't have any
reserves in the bank,
you have to sell your product.
And you're not able to
compete at these prices.
It's a recipe for disaster
if you're a mid-size company.
So small companies can survive
in what I call spore mode.
They're like a spore.
They don't have that big
manufacturing line to pay for.
They can survive
off grants, they
can survive off venture capital.
And their cash burn
rate is very low,
they're developing technologies.
The big companies have
cash cushions already,
they have cash reserves.
They might even be able to
access low interest rate
loans from banks
that borrow money
at ridiculously low rates
from the treasury right now.
They may even have
financial branches
within their own
company, like GE Finance,
that can do that sort of thing.
So big companies are,
so far, surviving,
the really tiny companies
are, so far, surviving,
but the market dynamic
is really hitting
those mid-size companies that
already have a manufacturing
line.
And so you hear about layoffs,
you hear about job losses.
These are often the
mid-size companies
just trying to go
back to spore mode
so they can survive this
difficult period until prices
equilibrate.
And when we look at
price is equilibrating--
let's look at the price now.
We're headed towards Q4 2011.
Let's put a data point
right here for Q4 2011.
Let's do it right now.
So I'll go back here
and-- sorry about that.
That was me
registering a website.
That's for the project
that Doug was working on.
We'll go to PVinsights.
And we're going to add the
latest data point here.
So solar wafer-- this is
silicon, this is wafer,
this is cell, and
this is module.
All right.
This is our low,
this is our high.
These are all prices in
dollars per watt peak.
Prices.
Our low and our high
and our average for-- I
guess, last update
was yesterday.
The low-- I can tell you this
particular low number right
here came from a tier three
manufacturer in China.
What is tier one,
tier two, tier three?
So tier one are brand names.
Yingli-- they advertised
during the World Cup.
Suntech, mentioned in Secretary
Chu's presentation yesterday.
Trina Solar, LDK, and so forth.
These are tier one
manufacturers, the big dogs.
Tier three are companies
you've never heard of
but are employing
thousands of people
and manufacturing modules in
the hundreds of megawatts range.
Perhaps even reaching
a gigawatt scale.
And because banks have
never heard of them
either-- maybe that's
an overstatement,
but I'm making a point here.
They're not as
well known, they're
not as reliable from
the bank's perspective.
Maybe they haven't
been around as long
and it's questionable
whether they're
going to survive this
difficult economic climate.
They have difficulty
to sell their product.
The installers don't want
to take their product.
And so they have to
undercut the competition.
They have to leave
money on the table.
And selling at prices
at $0.75 per watt.
Now, what Doug's
calculations are indicating--
as you saw from the
very beginning--
the cost of manufacturing
in the US is around $1.30.
The cost of manufacturing
in China is around $1.00.
And then you have to
ship it over to the US.
So if somebody is
willing to sell
you a module at 0.75
dollars per watt,
that means that the
price is below the cost.
That means that that company
is desperate to get rid
of inventory.
They must have modules stacking
up in their shipment yard.
They're unable to move them.
And so the chief financial
officer walks over and says,
we got to get rid of this stuff.
It's costing us money.
It costs us money to keep
this product on the books.
Sell it for whatever you have
to sell it for to get rid of it.
And as a consequence, they
sell below cost, put it out
into the market.
And then you have
SolarWorld, or a US company,
coming to the Department
of Commerce saying,
they're dumping product.
It's an unfair competition.
According to the World
Trade Organization,
you can't sell at a
price below your cost
in order to squeeze out
and gain market share.
So it's a complex
situation right now.
I've described for you, in
as much detail as I can,
my impression of what's
happening in the world today.
This low price right here, of
0.75 from a Chinese tier three
manufacturer.
And the high price here
coming from, most likely,
a German supplier
or US supplier.
Selling what is known to
be a very high quality,
reputable, product, has been
selling for the last 10 years.
Very reliable, very few
incidences of consumers
returning the product.
And banks like that product.
So they're able to extract
a premium for their product.
They're able to sell and move
those modules at a higher price
because they're more bankable.
This average right here is more
representative of what Chinese
tier one manufacturers are
currently selling for, and what
many of the US and European
average module makers are
having to compete against with
costs on the order of $1.30.
That's the
constriction right now.
So if we add that one data point
onto this chart right here,
where we have Q4 2011-- we're
solidly in Q4 right now--
and we're at 0.98 with an error
bar somewhere around here.
So we're at 0.98.
You see the prices
are still coming down.
And will likely come down
for maybe another quarter
before they start to stabilize.
And as companies fail--
as more companies leave
the market-- you'll have
consolidation of market share,
you'll have the few
remaining companies
that had the large cash cushion,
that had the lowest cost
structure, survive.
And increase their market
share and reduce the number
of players out on the market.
And probably, prices will
come back up afterwards.
Because you can't
continue selling
below cost for very long before
everybody goes out of business.
I saw a hand going
up over there.
AUDIENCE: I guess, those
prices-- a transaction happened
at that price, or that
was just the asked price
of the the manufacturer?
PROFESSOR: So these
right here-- I
know that the 0.75,
that was an offer price.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it was 0.85 during Solar
Power International in Texas
about a month ago.
And it made a big
splash and everybody
was really awed by it.
The 0.75 is news to me.
It probably came up over
the last week or so.
And in response, most likely,
to that company selling
at 0.85-- unable to move
their product-- going
even lower in a desperate
attempt just to get rid
of their inventory.
AUDIENCE: But these
are offered prices?
The transaction hasn't happened
at that price as of yet?
PROFESSOR: So these
prices, most likely,
are coming from a
few different routes.
So you, as an individual,
can send an email or fax
over a request for
a quote from any one
of 100 module manufacturers
around the world.
And you will get a quote
back or an offer sheet back.
And most likely, what
PVinsights is doing
is some combination of
that-- a guerrilla tactic,
let's gather information.
And as well, information gleaned
from their installer base.
So they have contacts to
various installer companies.
They keep the finger on
the pulse over there,
talking to their friends saying,
how much are they offering you
the modulus for?
AUDIENCE: It's not
like the stock market,
where the price sold
at is subjective?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The sell and the buy price
are a little different.
No-- or currency
exchange markets.
No.
These are individual
companies trying
to assess what the
market is willing to pay
for their product.
In the case on
the low end, these
are desperate producers
trying to move product.
And on the high end,
these are companies
with high cost structures,
typically, in the west--
typically US and Germany--
that have a reputation.
And they are
clinging for as long
as they can on to
the high prices.
For as long as they can do it,
before the market finally says,
you know what?
I'm sorry.
We've been good friends.
We've worked together
for the last 10 years.
But honestly, I'm not
going to buy it $1.45.
Not when Suntech is offering
me a module at $1.05 and it's
comparable in quality.
They've proven themselves.
The days when all Chinese
modules were inferior are over.
Now we have several tier
one Chinese manufacturers
that have proven their modules
out in the open market.
There hasn't been a
large number of recalls.
So I'm willing to take
the risk with them.
And at that point, you'll start
to see the higher priced US
and European products
begin to soften.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If the
oversupply condition
doesn't get resolved
in enough time,
does it have the
potential to, basically,
stall the entire industry?
And if so, how long
would that take?
PROFESSOR: Well, keep in mind
that this is just the module.
There's a whole other dynamic
happening on the installation
side.
And the reason I'm not getting
into that in too much detail
is because it varies so much
from country to country.
Although I will
say a few comments
before the end of class.
If the oversupply
condition continues
and if the feed-in
tariffs continue
to be low, what you'll see
is a continued softening
of the module price
into the point
where almost all
manufacturers are selling
below manufacturing costs.
They're all desperately trying
to reduce manufacturing costs,
reduce overhead.
It's forcing them to innovate--
at least in manufacturing
innovation-- faster.
Not on product
innovation, not on,
how do we design this
cell differently?
But more on the
process innovation
on the line of saying, gee,
how do we mix the silver
with the cheaper metal
like aluminum in a ratio
so that we eek out half
a cent per watt peak?
Because any small fraction
counts at this point.
We're desperate.
And you can think of
this oversupply condition
as a bunch of horses
running nose to nose.
And which ones will
begin falling out?
In the beginning, you could
point to easy candidates.
Those that have already
begun to go by the wayside.
But now, companies are burning
through the cash cushion,
reporting negative profits.
You see right and left, even the
Chinese tier one manufacturers
are reporting negative
earnings this last quarter.
So that's a reflection not only
of the oversupply condition,
but also the fact that
they're continuing to expand,
despite the
oversupply condition.
The idea being, well, we can
withstand one, two, three, four
quarters of losses as long as
we consolidate market share.
Once we emerge from this
oversupply condition,
we'll be able to increase
prices a bit more.
And then return to a
more sustainable market.
But we'll be the big dogs and
everyone else will be out.
So I think all companies
right now are trying
to play that game of survive.
Survive this oversupply
condition, make it through.
Some are able to continue
growing and other ones are
just stagnant.
So the stagnant ones are
going to become niche players.
They won't be the major
players in the market.
The ones who continue growing
will be 80%, 90% of the market.
AUDIENCE: Has there been talk
of increasing feed-in tariffs
to try to keep the
American companies alive?
PROFESSOR: So US doesn't
do many feed-in tariffs.
This goes back to the
US case right here.
So due to lack of leadership
at the national level,
there are a variety of state
level incentives put forth.
So these are the policies--
we kind of talked
about this last class, but to
dive into a bit more detail.
The rebate programs for
the renewables-- these
are state programs
plus the utility
and/or nonprofit programs.
Utility, local, and/or
nonprofit programs only
and state programs only.
So you see, for example, in
the state of Massachusetts,
we have what used to be the
Massachusetts Technology
Collaborative.
There was a bit of a power
struggle within Mass State
and it got incorporated into a
more centralized organization
downtown.
So that used to be in a
nonprofit organization, which
is now more affiliated
with the state.
The state also has a rebate.
We have a very different set of
ways of doing things than, say,
California, which has a
clean energy commission that
rates each module and
gives you a rebate
depending on what they rate
the module as performing
in California.
So every state has its
own way of doing things
and it becomes very
complicated very quickly.
To enact a national incentive,
beyond the tax rebate
that is already offered
today, is challenging,
in this political
climate especially.
Because anything
that you would do
to raise the cost of something,
which most likely would come
from some federal
program-- right now,
the Republican
Party is demanding
that there be an offset, a
reduction of spending elsewhere
within the government.
Many of the places that are easy
to cut have already been cut.
And so you've gone
through the fat.
You're now hitting muscle,
and pretty soon you're
going to be hitting bone.
So it's difficult
to enact something
that the government
would pay for.
It is even more difficult
to enact something
that the utilities
and rate payers would
pay for at a national
level because, oftentimes,
those powers are
delegated to the states.
And you would enter a
federal versus state
fight over that, which would
go to the courts, most likely,
and be held up there
for several years.
There are about 18,000 different
independent jurisdictions
within the United
States governing
how solar is added to the grid.
And so what the
Department of Energy
has done, which I think
is the wisest thing
to do-- given this situation
that we have-- is to say, OK,
we're not going to
force anybody to change,
but we're going to give an
incentive for people to change.
And like they had in the
Department of Education--
the race to the top,
where states competed
against each other to implement
best practices in education--
they're having a similar
program on the installation
side of solar, trying to get
various states to adopt a best
practices.
To streamline the
permitting process
to get solar onto the grid
in the most efficient way
possible, and hopefully
reduce the installation costs
associated with that.
So let's turn our
attention, quickly,
to installations, since
I want to give some time
to have people ask questions
about their class projects.
Since time is
running very short,
if you're hitting up
against a roadblock,
I want to make sure
that we resolve that.
I'll say a couple of words
about the installation.
So a funny thing happened
on Tuesday night.
I met with a colleague
from Wisconsin.
And he said, well, I
met the editor of-- I
think it was an editor from
one of the big journals.
We'll protect the innocent.
And this was a very
high-impact scientific journal.
And he said, well, the
majority of the cost right
now is in the installation side,
not in the module, in solar.
So I'm not going to be
interested in any papers
to my journal that describe
new concepts for PV modules.
I'm interested in
the installation side
because that's where the
majority of the cost is.
And I went, oh my
goodness, here's
another one who
can't distinguish
between cost and price.
So the installation cost right
now-- let's focus on cost first
and then we'll get to price.
So the installation cost
in the United States
is partially
reflective of the fact
that we have those 18,000
different ways of doing it
here, versus in Germany, there
is one way to do it nationally.
The federal government
said, we are
going to demand that
everybody in Germany
install in this protocol.
And the paperwork
is very, very brief.
It's a couple of pages
to get it installed.
And the inspection is one.
And so Germany has a much
more efficient system.
And they've installed roughly
six to seven times more solar
than we have.
And if we remember
experience learning curves,
when you have the reduction
of cost the more you do it,
that means you have
three doublings.
Germany has three
doublings over us.
And even if you assume a
very leisurely 20% reduction
for each doubling, that means
Germany is about the half
of the cost as we are,
because they've done more.
They know how to do it more
efficiently than we do.
OK.
So that's on the cost side.
On the price side, if
you look around the US,
you have some states
like New Jersey,
which had an amazing
incentive program for a while.
And California's as
well, quite generous.
So there are
certain states where
it's almost like a gold mine.
And so there's no
incentive for the installer
to reduce their price.
Their costs can be going
down, but their price
can be maintained high.
And usually-- this
isn't always the case,
but in most industries--
when prices are high,
the industry becomes lazy.
Now this isn't always the
case, but is often the case.
It is not atypical that
when the prices are high,
the industry says, oh, prices
are high, that's pretty good.
I'm enjoying myself right now.
I'm not going to be
focused on cost reduction.
It seems that, at least, the
lower level managers suddenly
become fixated on cost
reduction when it's too late.
When margins have
already begun shrinking,
when prices are collapsing,
and when it's do or die
for the company.
Then, all of sudden,
cost becomes imperative.
So there are very few companies.
The ones that usually
become leaders
are the ones who
recognize, gee, prices
can't remain high forever.
We have to reduce our costs now.
And hey, it'll be
even to our benefit,
because our margins
will be greater.
We'll be able to take
advantage of this right
now and build up some cash,
so that when the prices do
collapse, we have some buffer.
And we can survive the
oversupply condition.
So installers, right
now, I have to say
I'm disappointed in our
installers in the United States
for not doing more
amongst themselves
to reduce the
amount of paperwork.
For not taking a leadership
role in reducing the paperwork
burden.
And the true cost of installing
PV on the balances system,
[INAUDIBLE] installation side.
I think that's a very
resolvable problem.
You look to Germany and you have
residential systems going in
for below three euros
per watt peak price
taking advantage of the low
module prices right now.
And the fact that the
installation costs in Germany
are low, as well.
Because they've learned
how to do it well,
they've learned how
to do it efficiently.
And they've reduced
their cost structure.
So I personally-- I think
there is innovation to be
done on the installation side.
I think there's a lot that can
be done with pre-fabrication.
Maybe moving a
robot out there that
can assemble things in a big
rack and then a crane that
puts it on the roof.
As opposed to having 10
people going out to a house
and spending a couple days
putting panels on the roof.
It's not that bad.
Maybe it's more like a day.
But it's still a very
labor-intensive industry
right now in the US.
So more innovation can be done.
But the lion's share of
the installation price
right now is driven
by what I would
call inefficiencies in the
way installation is done
and inefficiencies in the way
the permitting process is done,
the paperwork is done.
So that's my soapbox
speech on installation.
By all means, there is
innovation to be done.
So don't give up on
that side either.
It's important.
It's where the
rubber hits the road.
But I think you can't just look
at the price of modules today
and the price of installing
the system today in the United
States-- and realize that
80% of the price right
now is wrapped up in
the installation--
and say, oh, well, there
isn't any more innovation
to be done on the module side.
You have to look at cost.
And you have to recognize
that the module cost is
driven by the efficiency
of the module.
And the installation
cost, as well,
will be driven by the
efficiency the module.
And so the module being
the engine of the system
is still very, very,
very important.
And so the work that folks are
doing-- on new PV materials,
especially-- is important.